Counter-Strike Global Offensive is one
of the most popular games on Steam but
that hasn't stopped rumors that the game
will soon get a massive update that will
transform it overnight according to a
new report from journalist Richard Lewis
sources have confirmed that a
hypothetical Counter-Strike 2 is indeed
real and the Planned release date for
the beta is March or early April the
report suggests that this new game will
be on the source 2 engine rather than
the Aging original Source engine that
powers Counter-Strike Global Offensive
it will feature an improved matchmaking
system and 128 tick servers intended to
compete with its major rival in the
competitive shooter space valorent it's
unclear if the two versions of
Counter-Strike will co-exist or if valve
plans to pull an OverWatch and replace
the original Global Offensive entirely
it's also likely that the move to Source
2 will require higher minimum specs to
run well counter strike 2 would actually
be the fifth Counter-Strike the original
Counter-Strike was a third party mod for
valve's seminal game Half-Life those
developers and the rights to the IP were
purchased by Valve in 2000 before
launching the mod as a standalone title
that year four years later Turtle Rock
Studios would create the original
Counter-Strike 2 with Counter-Strike
condition zero with valve also releasing
a remake of the first game late that
year built with its at the time new
source engine while Counter-Strike
always had a cult following it wasn't
until 2012's Global Offensive that the
series truly took off with its regularly
leading steam's monthly charts by number
of players and being only second to Pub
G Battlegrounds in number of concurrents
another multiplayer FPS game coming soon
to steam is arcane's redfall but that
isn't the only storefront the title will
be releasing on starting May 2nd redfull
will also be available on the Xbox store
both on console and PC for purchase or
via Game Pass as well as the epic game
store sometimes when multiplayer games
have multi-platform releases such as
this like last year's Warhammer 40K dark
Tide players are segmented by storefront
I myself despite being able to play dark
tide via a PC game pass subscription
last fall had to pick up a copy of the
game via steam just because my friends
are a group of crusty tryhards that
refuse to do any PC gaming on any other
platform which really made me rethink
some of those friendships if that group
decides to be a pain in my ass again and
pick up redfull on Steam I can rest easy
knowing that I can play with them while
utilizing Game Pass as developer Arcane
has confirmed cross play across all
storefronts and platforms now will I
want to play with them that's an
entirely different question but the
option is there if I decide I do one of
steam's most popular games in recent
months has been Hogwarts Legacy which
also released on New Gen Con Souls along
with PC in February those that have yet
to make the jump to PS5 and the Xbox
series X or S have since had to wait for
the title to release on previous
generation platforms the game originally
dropping on PS4 and Xbox One on April
4th owners of those consoles are going
to have to wait a little longer however
as the last gen version of Hogwarts
Legacy has been delayed a full month to
May 5th and as a reminder anyone wanting
to play on switch will have to wait even
longer than that as the game has been
scheduled to release on Nintendo's
hybrid device on July 25th what do you
think about global offense of getting
this major Counter-Strike 2 revamp let
us know in the comments and we'll see
you here for more Gamespot news